today's episode is presented by t-mobile
America's best unlimited network hello
screen junkies along to the honest
trailer commentary for 1991's Point
Break and the only point Franks it plank
that right here the pea rookies
acknowledge is exist you got so upset
you couldn't even say to him and say it
point-blank all the other one should be
named remember exactly I'm Dan Merrill
next to me awesome jokes car and necro
today Gilbert Andy remains on vacation
any remains on vacation I never come
back
he may not never know the beard may stay
on the loose in Europe and will be like
a catch me if you can situation I had
too much Christmas Eve in France yes I
believe it's how that worked I don't
remember anyway guys we did this because
Kathryn Bigelow's new movie Detroit is
opening this week and fund a lot of
people don't know that oscar-winning
director Kathryn Bigelow directed Point
Break early her career pretty awesome I
think that shows some good range right
although they're all really tense action
movies I was struck when i rewatch Point
Break by how good action is actually
really good like the allegheny the
camerawork every other yeah yeah there's
no anyone else that I feel like this no
one would have ever seen Point Break
like anyone else directing well it would
have been cheesy yeah yeah and then
we've been really cheesy yeah would
magic it and don't go running it's
cheesy yeah this is a good amount of
cheese but it walks in like a really
fine line yeah there's high highs and
low lows they don't know that it's a
cheese I think Swayze knew what so
everyone in this movie seemed like the
sways was the guy that knew exactly what
movie they were may yeah like he rides
that light perfectly and John McKinley
and Keanu I think was a little too much
on the serious side yeah who's being
Busey then we really like Swayze and
interviews is like I relate to Bodie
more than any other character I've ever
played man so what did you buy into it I
don't know that's interesting yeah
because I mean Swayze was already like a
mega star at that point he's probably
living in Malibu and experimenting on
one of the guy diving enthusiasts he did
one of the jumps in this movie yeah so I
think like Patrick says he was Bodhi in
a really weird way and I don't know I
think this movie holds up
it's cheesy is but it's about as cheesy
as a bank-robbing surfers movie would be
yeah I don't know I I still like this
movie and I'm not really likable about
it there's just great imagery in it just
like the Regan mask its iconic the
reckons I'm getting the car on fire with
a guest
it's bigot is just awesome and there's
great lines that are so dumb you can't
stop saying them and yeah Kennedy reads
like I buy him as a surfer I buy his it
under as a effort granted surfer cop I
don't buy him as a cop but I behave as a
surfer so he has this thing that he does
I mean he's legitimately good at John
wick I'm talking about like in his
earlier movies
yeah he's dumbly earnest yeah he's very
dumb but very earnest about it there's
like that theory I can't remember who it
is so sorry if I'm not giving credit but
it's like he is the ultimate audience
stand-in because he's like a complete
blank yeah well they're always like on
experiencing the movie through him he's
like a stick figure
yeah oh that's me that's why we have
Point Break live yeah boy free gladiator
main yeah it's a live show here in LA
where they pulled the Keanu for the
night out of the audience and they read
the Point Break script off of cue cards
and may end up sounding like cannery
because it's pointing in Riya an FBI
agent that's pretty good yeah I like
this this is not a movie I grew up with
I saw this later and my life as an adult
I think when I first saw Point Break but
I still I like this movie I think it's
fun but guys let's you want to watch The
Australian's Cheerilee by Tom and Jerry
for Point Break
surprisingly easy to find requests for
those those where it might be known just
one in the middle
another point right before Kathryn
Bigelow tackled pretty dramas about the
Iraq war the hunt for bin Laden and the
Detroit play she went about bank-robbing
surfers ever been published and all the
community voted will be about thanked
robbing surfers ever made good point
ray great yeah yeah yeah when the Sun is
out and the surf is up the streets of LA
are hot with pride that's enough perfect
but then you were just at that sounds
like a line from the actual checkpoint
here's the thing we could maybe release
this there's two versions of this
trailer I wrote two versions uh-huh then
I wrote interval I wrote it with
sometimes we dip into the vault as we
did with Top Gun Grand Forks or meant
for and maybe one other one Captain
America's okay yeah yeah so I'd the
first draft I wrote this from the
perspective of a 1991 movie trailer and
so that was a definite definitely was
from that earlier draft yeah well I was
awakened too much well we talked about
it because I remember you wrote a draft
and we talked about it and I think we
decided like really there wasn't much
difference like you could change the
same things about this movie now as you
could in 1991 we lost some things like
you had to really twist yourself and
knots to get the John wick joke in and
stuff like that there's some things that
were a little more awkward but it would
just be like you when you see Gary Busey
be like wow that saying actor is really
good even crazier and stuff like that
which may have added more to it way
we'll do it in alternate version same
way I think I think we wrote that as
like a a retro and a lot of that sort of
survived and yeah in the final yeah yeah
talked about doing die hard is the retro
but we really we wanted to hit on the
fact that it was like the perfect action
movie you couldn't do from the vault
yeah from yeah from the wall yeah the
vault style you have to be very kid just
being old movie doesn't like a very
specific yes tone Top Gun was a great
could you talk about the mouth count
exactly oh boy let's get going hmm
priests of La are hot with crime now the
ex-presidents are robbing every bank in
town and the only way to stop them is to
hit the beach and catch some waves the
FBI is going to pay me to learn to surf
I love the 90s right along as a
blank-faced car falls in without
charismatic right that's right the
various candidates a waitress with a
personal connection to his target but
they're at and furious it's totally
resolved because in fact they drink
Coronas we're in Point Break they drink
also corroded
okay somebody owes someone money and
they've been sued I guess you can't Ferb
yeah boy laughs yeah I don't know I
think he has to be like you have to
legitimately ripoff like where where the
line is what is yeah it's they've
obviously stolen the premise and the
just character templates they did I
change the hobby yeah what or anything
yeah like I wonder if it'd have been
skateboards instead of surfboards
someone could have been like your honor
they both have wheels yeah that's the
language but even the last shots the
same the slow-motion walk and tossing
the badge yeah is is the same thing they
do the same I want to live in a world
where there's nine-point break right
more like anthony peden becomes like a
big movie star he becomes Tyrese hahaha
2.2 break yeah why probably not behind
in the break my part 9 we finally gave
really into war shun I just break eighth
grade point six and it only been made
ten years later yeah could have been the
modern day fast in the car man war child
Redemption we have some really great
arcs in there McKinley could have done
so much feature work oh my god oh man
Emmett well you'd have been Kurt Russell
more guys more events yeah like yes eyes
Mart who would the rocket bid to join it
probably like well no late 90s it
probably been the rock probably earlier
strangely eventually a young rock yeah
it's young heavy rock yeah it would have
been good but his name was still Dakota
crush coma crush you say cerflan man
it's like Savannah sorry I'd be making
this up no another difference no it's
worse it's flex cavanna there you go
Keanu Reeves is Johnny Utah undercover
agent when they're channeling any joint
Johnny Utah so hyoe state [ __ ] guys on
remember wait what it's like sending Tim
Tebow to bust a gang of roller bladers
which I would also be totally in alters
and that was Bojan watch um roles like
Ted Theodore Logan where Joan of Arc
Noah's wife to a guy who's pretending to
be dumb like Ted Theodore Logan did your
life bro hello moto he has a be chilling
don't forget hair long clipping hair
hands off be right now don't go [ __ ]
when I say dumbly Ernest yes that is put
that in the FBI agent line that's what I
mean when I say dumbly Ernest like he
sound so dumb
yeah he's I think that point he does
know deep undercover that you just
become the dumb person a person a room
yeah he's like he dumped it off yeah I
must become him yes your hands o'clock
me may I
agent what if they're just takes where
he did the cadence of bed line I want to
see though that tie like I'm an FBI
agent Cassidy no just like no no no make
a meal really really doing them we're
all that out explore the space because
Anthony Hopkins did that a little bit
and it sounds enter all the way to the
FP oh maybe he was just he and Hopkins
is something probably greater always say
FBI and are really weird yeah how
amazing would it be if Anthony Hopkins
admitted like why did you say that line
like that is like well I just want to
point bravery Keanu were having lunch
together
do you have any advice you a snake
holding unwinnable and I said with
Anthony Kiedis yes without having a
cheerio dog I loved how you said the
good friend a better price which happens
with time together
ages Doc Brown this Keanu Reeves is
Marty and it to me out of this doc Brown
died well maybe somebody white nozzoli
alright
the voyage 11 off be right now right not
on you still had so much to learn
like don't kick a dog
you know one wig would kill you for that
process that really shines as the
baddest [ __ ] want bank robbing puta
Bodhi those ways later my jontron fall
hard for each other at one Hill kid out
a girl who give you away and frankly
returning the correct letter for the
Metro there in the matrix previously
which each raising you know everyone
could ask why you don't remember okay
first come out on our database be yeah
this is the music we used for the neo
Morpheus Winter Soldier and cab romance
and then yeah Winter Soldier and cat
it's a bromance music yeah this the
second time Keanu gets to use it go find
me honest trailer for the matrix I think
we say it there we probably did we
probably dug it our I don't remember
yeah what's the stairs one called oh boy
would assist I used to know by heart and
now I don't anymore it's a great name I
don't remember it done kind of yeah you
can find that for sure
yep 11 as this romance heats up to the
extreme I'm uh having some people over
my house tonight if you want to come
we are going to ride this all the way to
us you and me so let's go how can you
not fall for an early morn right yes I
make look I love I uh get lost why
didn't my eyes baby blue easy Dhoni we
actually connect she won't be too bad I
can't with your mouth oh yeah I want you
in my mouth I mean hell yeah I want to
go surfing because they're covered
supporting performances by the Red Hot
Chili Peppers the mean boss from Scrubs
your honor night a ranting unhinged
performance by Gary Busey that we should
have recognizes the cry for help that it
was this is jump after taste dot while
you work wrap it in your hands and rub
it on your face I wonder if any of that
women in this grid Oh
who rev it ahead Kathryn Bigelow shows
the boys how it's done display her
mastery of high stakes high C's accurate
use of surfer lingo honey Brown rah rah
don't worry about a product I can't do
it bro there's something wrong and for
some reason a world full of really hazy
interiors very 90s
every room and Point Break full of hate
it won't have reservations I did not
have like filters that they do now or
they no I don't know is a very 80s and
90s thing of just like every room is
filled with haze every Street at night
is soaking wet and reflective like
because every single covered or seam
that's probably part of it rooms yeah
hazy herb and there was also before a
beer and yellow low emissions vehicles
so I guess the smog was worse in LA
that's true growing up in LA did like
this guy was brown mustache yeah it had
gotten better that's good so yes it
looks like Point Break I didn't look
like that is nothing yeah I think part
of it was you could smoke inside part of
it is just like that was just the
atmosphere yeah I think they're like
it's time to shoot Hank and like this
old man with like a bee smoker comes in
addition anyone over did it roll it as
well hang come on crab
keyonna to go back up again black yacht
agree hey I kind of got in my lives
ahead mom
okay every room in Point Break full of
haze so buckle up for an adrenaline soak
thrill ride between lines you'll be
quoting for decades you talk to give me
two - I am an FBI agent actors who
overwhelm you with charm and charisma
and a premise so stupid only the dumbest
movie studio would ever try to recreate
that can't be magic again yeah I'm just
gonna pretend that not the only way you
can do that first of all I watched that
on video
very [ __ ] awful thing travesty oh it
is so so bad and it's even hard to even
put my finger on why exactly it's bad
because it's bad for all possible
reasons name someone and it's bad for
that reason cinematography so bad shaky
cam Lee it's the whole thing was filmed
on a GoPro it looks terrible of action
the action is so lame like the whole
thing just looks like a like a bad
Mountain Dew commercial as Lori petti in
it now I don't know I don't think anyone
ever involved in it but I think the only
way you could have revisited Point Break
is like 21 Jump Street in it and just
like being like this is a comedy now
there's no good way to reboot Point
Break yeah I'm sure he is kind of a
reboot of Point Break in a weird way
yeah a little bit but funny I just think
the movie is so like it's it's a weird
it can't be like you need to approach it
and to be self-aware if you're going to
bring back Point Break it's such a weird
perfect storm it's such a weird 50 years
one of your hundred years oh yeah like I
just don't think you can I think you can
I think it's I think they've proven it
son makeable like it's such a just it's
the right director and the right cast
and the right time yeah right yeah the
right time is big for them 2091
they will remake Point Break yes
everyone under you everyone son to
everyone every 100 years only because
every 100 years so like this and like
pump up the volume are just like 1990
and you can't ya can reduce there you go
it's one of those all right let's finish
story FBI agent Patrick Swayze Manic
Pixie Tank Girl
Hank girls cariann see the requisite
angry police chief ad flip-flop dipper
don't go Canada across Cali California
Orange over aa good poet Donnie Brasco
thank you say what you will about their
music but the Red Hot Chili Peppers have
randomly been in some of the best movies
ever I can pause them like a little boat
to correct us but that's well barrel yes
we are in so probably in some of us to
put a joke inside a joke but folks now
it's great that we are aware that that's
not say we know that Will Ferrell is not
to Jeffers however I mean many people
believe that they are indeed related or
the same person yeah I'm surprised we
did not highlight fleas roll as needles
ending back to the future
yeah oh yeah yeah right it's lag please
been a bunch of good stuff yeah so
probably the best acting band of all
time
that's for shanthi been in anything I
want to know want a joke about that okay
yeah I don't know yeah or the Jane's
Addiction guy entourage thank you right
there yeah we have we have outtakes so
we have some alternate starring is I
think we had a couple alternate openings
stuff for this one let's take a look
from James Cameron's wife three out of
five please bill Kathryn Bigelow was
making our touring drama about a
state-appointed missing bank-robbing
surfers II
ever made and also the only bank-robbing
surfer movie ever made
starring Keanu Reeves
Johnny Utah Esquire Gidget goes
undercover school Joe Montana I like Joe
Montana he because uh Johnny you tossed
Gary
- meatball sub sure about dink and don't
want those scrubs yeah all right ready
oh yeah you know those are great
character names in this way with a
Johnny Utah and Johnny meadow D bode I
can't remember the other ones Warchild
Korsakoff dog or child that got war
child that was actually I remember I
heard Edgar Wright talking about because
Hot Fuzz obviously Point Break was a big
influence on Hans buzzing I remember him
saying that back off war child for him
was the turning point in that movie
where he thought that Keanu Reeves
started going to Patrick Swayze side and
then the breaking point was Gary Busey
asking for two meatball subs and he was
like all right that's that guy imma go D
by a knockout for child I guess is like
a great is the turning point of Point
Break
those were emotional turning points but
um kind of are though I guess those
scenes yeah I don't know if it's that
line maybe we can revisit like if it
cuts away to Keanu's face like heads the
moment but back to create one child they
are two of the most quotable parts of it
so oh yeah no no maybe they work on a
deeper level maybe so so guys Point
Break I like it I like it a lot there's
a Robin Montrealers yeah I'm curious to
see how many people watch it and a lot
of times the older movies don't not as
many people are interested in watching
it but we had fun with that yeah I will
say we went to the front just based on
those intro lines I want Spencer to
write a novel just like a real pulpy
weird okay Beach suspense novel when the
Sun is down there's when the Sun is up
la is not the crowd yeah I think I'm
just good at writing tagline but not a
terrible you know bad poster taglines
have gotten like you could write some
kickass poster - there are business
brother yeah you're right okay
well food for thought guys this has been
Spencer's last honest trailer yes moving
on to pull close freelance writer
mark on a poster and a movie poster near
you until then
I'm Dan merle i'm joe star that's Jay
Gilbert and we will be back here next
week with the trailer for something that
we're not ready to tell you about Newark
I knew yeah something newer we'll see if
the older movie that not many people saw
does better than the newer movie that
not many people saw sure this is the
unstoppable force in the movie is the
saddest version so the worst version of
it until next time thanks for watching
this episode was presented by t-mobile
America's best unlimited network
you